chair and first director of the
congressional budget office afterwards
part of this weekend's book tv on c-span
2.
bertrand patanad research fellow at the
hoover institution recounts the life of
red army chief leon trotsky
kepler's books in mellow park california
host this 50-minute event
thank you all for coming out tonight
and uh let me just say great to be here
at my local bookstore keplers
this evening i'm going to highlight two
things most speakers get up and say
they're going to talk about three things
they're going to make three points i'm
not that ambitious just two things i'm
going to talk about and in fact
these are two myths
that die hard about trotsky
and his last years in mexico
the first
has to do with trotsky's affair with
frida kahlo most of you have heard about
this um if you haven't read about it
maybe you saw the movie i think it was
2004 the movie frida
which dwelled on this
the myth that dies hard is not that the
affair took place because of course it
did
and i describe uh the circumstances in
my book
in fact the myth is that frieda's
husband
diego rivera later found out about it
and that this led him to break off his
relationship with trotsky that's a myth
that's the first one
the second myth
has to do with a certain ice pick
and i should say spoiler alert trotsky
does not do well at the end of this book
the book focuses as megan said on the
last years of trotsky's life
in mexico so 1937 to 1940
with flashbacks though to pivotal
moments
in his uh earlier career as young
revolutionary
great orator of the russian revolution
of 1917
uh creator and leader of the red army
and then of course vanquished rival of
stalin
but let's start with diego
it was thanks to diego rivera the great
mural painter that trotsky landed in
mexico
stalin had routed trotsky in the battle
to succeed lenin who died in 1924
and then sent trotsky into exile he
actually first went to
turkey from there from turkey trotsky
eventually moved to france in 1933
then to
norway in 1935 until the political
pressure on the norwegian government
forced it to expel trotsky
now what do i mean by uh political
pressure
the first of the famous moscow show
trials took place in august of nineteen
thirty six
leading bolsheviks or i should say
leading communists were put on trial for
the most fantastic crimes uh including
assassination of stalin himself
uh attempted assassination anyway
espionage and so on
trotsky was portrayed as the mastermind
of a group of spies wreckers and
saboteurs
directing their operations from abroad
that trial the moscow show trial of
august 1936 was the first of three such
show trials each one involving major
political figures each time with trotsky
serving as the chief defendant in
absentia
so with norway wanting to be rid of
trotsky the only country in the world
that would take him was mexico
thanks to its radical president lazaro
cardenas
who thought it was the right thing to do
but also crucially thanks to the
intercession of diego rivera who called
himself a trotskyist i say called
himself advisedly more on that in a
moment and certainly was hated by the
mexican mexican communists
the decision by mexico to grant asylum
was controversial within mexico but
nonetheless it happened and trotsky and
wife natalia arrived there in january of
1937.
diego and frieda allowed trotsky and
natalia
to reside in their blue house the casa
azul in coyoacan then a suburb outside
mexico city now of course it's inc has
been incorporated into the city
rivera
was a vital source of funds for trotsky
in these first two years
selling off his paintings
and at one point even mortgaging his
house in nearby san angel
in order to help raise money for trotsky
for two things
one to support the household just
putting food on the table but also and
of increasing importance
money for trotsky's protection to pay
for guards to pay for weapons and so on
diego
and freda were at trotsky's side during
the dewey commission hearings held at
the blue house
in the spring of 1937 the dewey
commission being the independent inquiry
into the veracity of the moscow trials
led by the american philosopher and
public intellectual john dewey
the dewey commission eventually by the
end of 1937 issued a verdict of not
guilty in other words that the
outrageous charges against trotsky in
moscow had not been proved
it was after the departure of the dewey
commission
in the spring of 1937 the trotsky and
frida began their affair
frida's extramarital liaisons were
several i wrote numerous here and then i
crossed that out earlier and i put
several
because i should point out they were
nowhere near the number of her husband
who was a champion philanderer
trotsky's relations with frida
became known to have to talk about this
at some length in the book there's a
separate chapter devoted to it about
trotsky facing old age having this fling
the chapter title is man of october
trotsky uh
trotsky's affair with frida becomes
known to natalia
and for a while in that summer of 1937
this threatens the trotsky's marriage
they had a short separation that summer
exchanging letters back and forth some
with shockingly explicit sexual language
on trotsky's part it's all true i'm not
trying to sell books uh some very
as my father-in-law put it some naughty
pages uh in this book trotsky sort of
defying advancing old age um although at
the time
interestingly
trotsky feels he's getting old
he's 57
and this in this day and age we look
back 57 doesn't seem that old certainly
not from up here doesn't look that old
57 but he's called the old man by his
acolytes and he very much is feeling
that way
at this time beginning in the late 1930s
it was during that separation trotsky
was staying at a hacienda about a
10-hour drive from koyua khan it was
during that separation the trotsky and
frida decided to call a halt we're
pretty certain about this
now there's absolutely no evidence
that diego found out about any of this
either at the time or later on when the
friendship between trotsky and diego
began to disintegrate
had rivera discovered
uh that trotsky was having an affair
with his wife trotsky the great russian
revolutionary trotsky diego rivera's
hero
the man he had arranged safe haven for
in mexico uh diego might have ended
trotsky's life before stalin's assassin
had had a chance to do so
diego was famously jealous
uh a frida just jealous generally
always threatening people uh with a gun
in his hand
so i speculate here that had he found
out we would have heard some fireworks
trotsky would have heard some fireworks
for now
the friendship between trotsky and diego
remained strong
it was diego
who broke the news to trotsky in
february of 1938
that trotsky's older son
leova
it's a nickname for lev like lev trotsky
leova had died in a paris clinic after
an operation to remove his appendix
we'll probably never know
whether fall play was involved in the
part of the soviet secret police the
nkvd most books say well of course they
knocked him off it's not clear
but what is clear is that trotsky had to
assume that this was the case
trotsky's other children were by now all
dead
or had disappeared
a daughter xena died of natural uh no
nina died of natural causes in the ussr
tuberculosis in the 1920s another
daughter xena
died a suicide in berlin in 1933
and younger son sergey or city orga was
arrested in moscow that the trotsky's
knew what they did not know was that he
was shot
while trotsky was in mexico and still
alive
other family members of the trotsky's
had to endure a similar fate
as did most of trotsky's followers this
after all was the period of the great
the great terror
trotsky's paris organization
had been penetrated by the nkvd
in fact
son leova's closest confidante was an
nkvd agent
so it is conceivable that leova's death
was in fact murder
beginning especially in 1938 trotsky now
had to worry about the nkvd's presence
in mexico
and the reason for this was that the
spanish civil war was underway had been
since the summer of 1936
and spain
in those two years
had become a recruiting ground for the
nkvd
as general franco's phalanges forces
roll to victory
mexico becomes a haven
for refugees from the war defenders of
the republic to be sure
but they include nkvd agents or if not
agents certainly stalinist sympathizers
diego's help
in building up the defenses at the blue
house
and in hiring guards at this time
becomes critically important
those guards were mostly young americans
from new york and i mean new york city
but also
from minneapolis
where the trotskyists had actually put
down roots among the teamsters
organization it was the only place in
the country where the trotskyists really
had a following
among what trotsky called the
proletariat
some of those teamsters came to coyoacan
to serve as guards
and some less successfully than others
the teamsters it turns out were not all
cut out to be guards of trotsky or
anybody else
despite
diego's generosity at this time the
shortage of funds in the trotsky
household just to run the household but
also for his protection
is really quite shocking
one of the things i discovered in
researching the book they're always
running out of money
the guard fund runs out of money they're
asking natalya for natalya for funds
please don't tell trotsky and back and
forth and all around
also
what you you sort of get what you pay
for what you see is the poor quality
of some of the guards
and that's quite scandalous as well i
mean you can barely believe it
uh reading the documents or reading the
book that this is the the best that the
great trotsky could attract or the most
money he could uh attract to the till
trotsky himself is constantly
complaining about the quality of his
guards
and because of this
by 1939 he's really resisting being
guarded very important part of the story
to support himself
and the household trotsky is writing
as he has done through the 1930s the
period of his exile
he established his reputation
in the west really with his epic uh
history of the russian revolution
and his memoirs my life both published
in the early 1930s
now in 1938
out of desperation
trotsky agrees to write a biography of
stalin
the publisher is is harper uh the
predecessor of my uh my publisher
harpercollins
trotsky finds this very distasteful
he drags his feet about taking it on but
ultimately he decides that he has to do
it because he needs to protect himself
from stalin's assassins
so we have a situation where trotsky is
writing the biography of the man who's
trying to have him killed very
interesting
trotsky gets off to a fast start
with the biography in 1938
but the work becomes bogged down
not surprisingly when trotsky reaches
the part of the story
where stalin and trotsky face off in
soviet russia after 1917. he just can't
write those chapters he gets serious
writer's block
and also his health begins to fail
the return of a mysterious illness that
plagued him at critical moments in the
struggle for power in the 1920s
lethargy high blood pressure extremely
high blood pressure loss of appetite
not the fever
the fever that characterizes illness in
the 1920s does not return
this entire situation
the pressure for funds
the health concerns
publisher and literary agent on his back
that's the worst of it
becomes actually worse
in the fall of 1938
when the friendship between trotsky and
diego begins to fracture
now this has nothing to do with frida
frida kahlo
who was away
in new york
and then in paris exhibiting her work
this is the time when frida really comes
into her own as an artist she had been
in her husband's shadow up till this
time later by the way she would credit
trotsky's presence in mexico for really
having her career take off
inspiration to paint
and so on
so freda's away
so what explains the break
really the friendship between trotsky
and diego seems from the beginning
destined to go sour
uh you have on the one hand trotsky
rigid
prickly angular
and on the other diego reckless
riotous gargantuan the lion and the
elephant
diego bathed irregularly
dressed carelessly
seldom arrived on time for anything
trotsky meanwhile was a stickler for
neatness
regimen and routine both men
had tremendous work ethics but diego's
self-discipline was restricted almost
entirely to his painting
and with brush in hand he tended to lose
track of nearly everything else
on the day of the dead
november 2 today in 1938 diego walked
into trotsky's study at the blue house
and presented him with a sugar skull
not an unusual thing to do on day of the
dead this sugar skull had the name
stalin
spelled out across the forehead
um trotsky was not amused
and as soon as diego had left the house
he ordered his assistant to have the
offending object
destroyed a year ago i speculate trotsky
might have let that go but at this point
he had really become
sort of fed up
it all was unraveling
and the split came that winter
when diego went off the rails
politically in advance of mexico's
presidential elections they won't take
place till the summer of 1940 but
there's a long run up cardinals cannot
run again and so there's a real struggle
for power
diego was not a trotskyist it turns out
and even his marxism is open to question
diego was a free spirit if anything he
was a populist
given diego's very
public
political freelancing trotsky called it
zigzagging
trotsky felt he had no choice but to
move out of the blue house
and a new villa was found a few blocks
away and trotsky moved in
in may 1939
trotsky and diego would never meet again
at this point in the story another of
the big three mexican muralists david
alfaro siqueiros enters the story
trotsky had had a brief and very
stimulating meeting with the other great
mexican muralist jose clemente orozco
he they met in guadalajara summer of
1938 an encounter i described in the
book quite magical only a few hours uh
but trotsky was instantly in love with
orozco infatuated with him
si quieros was the late starter of the
three great muralists partly because he
was so heavily into
communist politics he took it very
seriously he wasn't a dilettante
like diego orozco wanted nothing to do
with not only communist politics but
anybody's politics by the 1930s in fact
sikiros
politically was diego's nemesis
here then the 2004 frida film is quite
accurate
sikiros
it's a long winding story but he goes
off to fight in spain that actually
already should tell you a lot about his
commitment
it is said it's very hard to determine
it for sure but it's said that siqueiros
commanded a brigade
and then a division of the republican
army in spain
and he attained the rank of lieutenant
colonel
and it was in spain that he was likely
recruited siqueiros was
by the nkvd
after his return to mexico in january
1939 ciceros began work on one of his
most important murals
it's in the stairwell of the mexican
electricians union still there i went to
see it when i was researching the book
it's a fantastic thing
portrait of the bourgeoisie it's called
it's nothing like it sounds it's quite
violent and epic
really one of the masterpieces of the
1930s mural art
so this was a
major activity for cicadas however
he was also involved in a different kind
of activity on the side
this one sponsored by the nkvd
he was enlisted to lead an armed
commando raid on trotsky's home
this took place
in the hours before dawn actually was
about 4 am
on may 24 1940
20 men
dressed in police and military uniforms
armed with machine guns cicadas had on
the uniform of an army major
these men entered the grounds
how did they get in wasn't trotsky well
guarded one of the american guards from
new york had been recruited by the nkvd
he opened the gate
once in place
inside the courtyard
the uh the the commandos the the
intruders set themselves up outside
trotsky's bedroom
and with trotsky's guards pinned down in
their quarters by machine gun fire these
intruders unleashed a barrage
of machine gun fire into the trotsky's
bedroom from three directions
rooms on either side and the outside
window
they also carried with them three
homemade bombs
only one of which went off in a room
adjacent to the bedroom clearly they
were trying to set the place on fire
they left after 15 minutes
believing they had done the job trotsky
must be dead
in fact they had failed trotsky and
natalya were unhurt they had ducked down
in a corner of the room
and they survived
trotsky's comrades uh call this the
miraculous escape and that's the the
title of the prologue to the book
because i begin with this attack
dramatic attack
on may 24
1940
now comes the frantic preparations for
the next attack
and the anticipation
is that it will be with bombs
the villa must be transformed into a
fortress
turrets must be constructed atop the
high walls
double iron doors must replace the
wooden entrance to the garage
steel shutters must cover the windows
bomb proof wire netting must be raised
and barbed wire barriers must be moved
into position
but even as those fortifications began
to rise up
the nkvd had decided to resort to its
fallback plan the assignment of
liquidating trotsky and the orders come
directly from the kremlin from stalin
that assignment would be entrusted to a
lone operative
who had managed to penetrate trotsky's
inner circle
he was
ramon mercader a spaniard recruited by
the nkbd in spain
during the spanish civil war
in paris
in the summer of 1938
disguised as a belgian student using the
alias jacques monard
he seduced
the sister of one of trotsky's former
secretaries former assistants
she was a brooklyn trotskyist she was
visiting paris by the name of sylvia
agaloff
mercader barnard
arrived in new york
in the fall of 1939 now using the name
frank jackson or jackson a canadian
businessman that was his new identity
sylvia knew about this as a front and
decided to go along with it
for her own reasons
she had no idea what he was up to and
had no idea that he belonged to the nkvd
he maneuvered sylvia down to mexico city
and he used her
to insinuate himself into trotsky's
household
he claimed to be
a heavy financial supporter of the
french trotskyists
back in paris
and of course by the summer of 1940
there's no way to verify this
right there's no way to contact the
french trotskyists because they're on
the run from the invading germans
the outbreak of the world war which
really
starts or is made possible by the nazi
soviet pact
of august 1939
struck a big blow
against trotsky and his followers in new
york city
new york city being at this time the
center of the international trotskyist
movement certainly wasn't paris at this
point
although i say the center of the
movement this is something else that's
quite shocking the total number of
trotskyists in the u.s was probably
never more than two thousand
paid you know members
when the war broke out
trotsky insisted that his followers
support the soviet union
despite the fact that the stalin regime
had wiped out his family and his
comrades
and of course was trying to have trotsky
killed
trotsky tried to justify the soviet
occupation of eastern poland as a result
of the nazi soviet pact
the baltics
the invasion of finland and the winter
war of
1939-40 which gave the red army a bloody
nose so to speak
trotsky said
we may not like it
but the red army is in fact spreading
socialism to these lands
the fact is in the soviet union we have
a worker state
it's a degenerated worker state trotsky
called it but nonetheless the state
there is state ownership of the means of
production
and so the occupied territories are
getting socialism at the end of a
bayonet so to speak with with the red
army uh bringing it in from the soviet
union
this is very curious because at this
very time
trotsky was saying worker state
degenerated worker state
but at the same time trotsky was very
openly uh calling the stalinist regime
totalitarian
and what's the other totalitarian regime
nazi germany
so for his followers in new york
primarily now
there's a lot of confusion they just
can't follow the old man not all of them
uh on this this line and trotsky is
insistent and this is taking up all his
time the biography of stalin that's on
hold the world war really and and what
to do what position to take on uh the
soviet union and on the invasion of
finland and so on that really is uh
center stage now
the debates among the american
trotskyists uh leads to a split
the party is small enough
but there's sort of a rule of these
parties on the left that if they're
really small they ought to split and
become smaller right
and this is what happens now
there is a majority those of you who
know your russian history
read bolsheviks into this because that's
how trotsky oftentimes uh referred to
these two groups the majority capital m
supporting trotsky although really
shakely at times
especially after finland in in which
begins in december 1939 and which leads
to the expulsion of the soviet union
from
the league of nations
the minority capital m
want to condemn soviet military
aggression outright and deny that the
ussr was a workers state of any kind and
they were very angry angry with not only
trotsky's position
but the way he argued it basically
comparing the minority to the old
mensheviks calling them petty bourgeois
complainers and so on and when they got
mad about that calling them enraged
petty bourgeois which really got them
mad you know
sylvia
agaloff the brooklyn trotskyist
who's the cat's paw in the story
took the side of the minority
and when she got to mexico city
she was invited to debate
come to trotsky's house and debate with
trotsky and the guards
in trotsky's study in koyua khan
this is where ramon mercader saw his
opening
he posed as a supporter of trotsky and
the majority
he wrote he was he knew very little
about politics and he was very awkward
about it and it should have been clear
and it was clear to everyone around
trotsky but nonetheless they went along
with this
ricotta wrote a draft of an article
defending the majority position
and he had it ready in august 1940 and
he asked trotsky to read it
he maneuvered to be alone with trotsky
just the two of them in the late
afternoon of august 20 as the guards
were busy installing a new siren that
had just been received from the comrades
in los angeles
mercado whom trotsky assumed was a
canadian businessman by the name of
frank jacques
someone who sympathized with the cause
and was a potential source of much
needed funds
mercado entered trotsky's study with him
at about 5 30 that afternoon of august
20 carrying his trench coat
inside the coat was a dagger
a handgun
and a pickaxe
not an ice pick
a pickaxe
one end was pointed
like an ice pick the other was flat and
wide
the handle about a foot long had been
cut down for concealment
trotsky and his assassin all alone
and the rest is up to you
thank you
[Music]
if you have questions
um
if you would step up to the microphone
uh right over here
and we have a question
this is a long walk for a question but
it's worth it because people can hear
[Music]
i'm curious about uh stalin's role as a
young man in financing can you is this
can you hear this it doesn't sound as
though it's on
well we can all hear you i think that's
a high technique uh i'm curious about
stalin's role as a young man
in georgia
engaged in all of his criminal
activities there bombing oil fields and
robbing banks and this and that
if he was financing trotsky's
exile or trotsky's existence prior to
the russian revolution
whether stalin financed trotsky's
existence prior to the russian
revolution i've read in biographies that
stalin had financed lenin
prior to the revolution and i wondered
if his uh the money that he was
generating through his nefarious
activities was also
supporting trotsky okay um interesting
question um and much written about it
recently there's a book a biography
called young stalin by simon sebag
montefiore that talks about this um
still controversial whether this is
overdone
uh trotsky's uh sorry stalin's role in
bank robberies before the war
robbing banks in order to support
bolshevik operations immigrate
operations
without sort of wading into that
quagmire i can just tell you that
trotsky was not a bolshevik until 1917
so not even indirectly was trotsky
funded by that
in fact let me just say
that trotsky
was
an early acolyte of lenin
but when the
party the russian social democratic
labor party split
into bolsheviks and mensheviks at a
congress the second congress of that
party in 1903
trotsky ended up on the side of the
mensheviks
now if he were here he would immediately
butt in and say but but i i didn't stay
with them and in fact he broke with the
mensheviks as well trotsky was talk
about free spirits i mean trotsky was a
kind of
a freelancer as well in a very serious
way
um but the fact is that for all those
years
from 1903 right up to 1917
trotsky was one of lenin's most vocal
critics
and all of those criticisms
would come back to haunt trotsky
after lenin dies in 1924
and stalin and those others around
stalin who want to make sure that
trotsky doesn't succeed lenin
they use those quotes
so in a way trotsky joins the bolshevik
party 1917 he realizes it's the only
show in town he's the great orator of
the russian revolution he is in fact the
mastermind of the october
coup d'etat if you will and not all of
you will
but the coup d'etat uh of 1917
and um uh so he becomes a very important
bolshevik but
trotsky remains an outsider within the
party
and he had enough
in his background enough political
baggage
so that his menshivism quote unquote was
always being dragged out against him and
he would always say but i wasn't i
didn't belong to the mensheviks but
nonetheless it was anti-bolshevism
other questions
anybody want to step up
here we go we have one here and if you
would use the microphone or
we have a gentleman coming around here
actually you may want to just wait a
moment here we go
just sort of continuing with the
struggle between stalin and trotsky and
the developments from the time of this
of the russian civil war onward but i
haven't read the book sufficiently yet
or much of trotsky's writing by the end
of his life or when he was in exile in
mexico for these years for these years
that better
this mike
needs i'll repeat it i'll repeat the
question um what what opinion if any
had trotsky come to
regarding his defeat in the internal
struggle how did he explain it to
himself and what lessons did he draw
from that okay very good question how
did trotsky explain his defeat to stalin
um hardly rationalize it
in fact this is a central part of my
book
what really bothered
trotsky
was that this nobody stalin defeated him
stalin was the gray blur
famously called in 1917 during the
revolution he wasn't one of the stars of
the bolshevik party
and yet
stalin pretty handily defeated uh
trotsky
in the 1920s we talk about the trotsky
stalin conflict really was no conflict i
mean trotsky went down uh very quickly
in part because
trotsky was a poor politician stalin was
a very able politician
and
also trotsky's anti-bolshevik pass which
i told you about um and other political
ideological issues were brought in those
are the two big ones but for trotsky
the idea that stalin
the georgian you know the peasant
asiatic eastern guy defeated the great
trotsky one of the great leaders of the
revolution
really obviously bugged him and the way
he explained it
was
by saying that stalin was really
a nobody still but he represented a
bureaucracy
that had essentially taken over the
soviet uh organism sort of captured it
a bureaucratic stratum if not class
that had really hijacked the revolution
it was still a workers state
but this bureaucratic class was a
parasitic
parasitic entity that had to be removed
so for trotsky he wasn't defeated by a
person he always hated the question how
did you lose power oh he hated the
question and it was asked all the time
he meet he would meet somebody on the
street randomly and there's a scene i
describe uh in turkey
where somebody says oh my gosh the great
trotsky and bodyguards are there and you
shake shakes hands how'd you lose power
uh he hated it like you know uh
like you know how did you lose your
wallet
and he basically had to stop and say and
he would talk your ear off
that it wasn't about stalin the
individual it was about the impersonal
forces of history much easier to deal
with it personally
if you describe it that way
question right here
just on a on a sarcastic note
you had the the russian revolution
and uh
then you had the battle between uh
stalin and trotsky
stalin takes power and kills millions
and millions of people right
okay
was all this worth a revolution i mean
why not just stick with the uh
with the uh russian aristocracy why why
why did
russia go through all this and isn't it
typical
of uh history that this type of thing
happens
just your opinion well that's one of
those big questions i'm actually uh
teaching a course in the stanford
history department on modern russia
right now and this is just the kind i
mean this is sort of like the theme of
the course
and it would take a long time to answer
the question
the fact is
trotsky always said
that everything was worth it through the
october revolution
and a few years beyond
and that that all you had to do was to
oust that parasitic regime
and you would have the restoration of
democracy
of workers democracy and of true sort of
soviet uh democracy
in fact trotsky's problem
is that he wasn't a proponent of
democracy while he was in the soviet
leadership
only when he was being defeated
did he recognize the virtues of inner
party democracy and he wasn't talking
about uh democracy beyond that
and in fact
um if you look at the first trials these
aren't the show trials but there are
trials beginning in 1928 29 30. a lot of
people don't know about these they're
not
the show trials of the major bolshevik
leaders
but of engineers
of specialists in various fields of the
mensheviks in 1931 and for those trials
trotsky is living abroad he's in turkey
and he's supporting what stalin is doing
in fact criticizing stalin
for not going far enough later he would
apologize for this
um so but trotsky had a credibility
problem
when it came to uh being a quote unquote
democrat uh and that's sort of part of
the larger question you're asking which
you know is more of a rhetorical
question
but would take a long time to answer
other questions
yes sir
has the opening up of the soviet
archives
after the fall of the soviet union
added additional information on your
story
um
if not what would be the primary sources
particularly for the ncaa part of it
and the mexican side during the his
mexican residence
very good question and the question is
whether the opening up
of the archives the former soviet
archives uh influenced my book and i'll
open it up
generally and talk about other
scholarship
the short version is that when the
soviet union collapses
and boris yeltsin becomes president
there is this period not to go back and
say that the yeltsin years were idyllic
um but there was this period
when we had and i mean when i say we i
mean western researchers as well as
russian
had a lot of access
to
soviet archives including some nkvd kgb
archives that access
really has come to an end since the
ascendancy of putin
but i benefited greatly from the access
that was given in let's say the first
eight years of the 1990s or the first
eight years after the fall of the soviet
union
because what happened is when you didn't
have western scholars going into the
nkvd kgb archives which really uh
remained mostly closed during this
period
you had russian scholars and others uh
in fact russian agencies the russian
successor to the successor to the kgb
itself publishing books of documents
and here
i had great material come out about the
plot to assassinate trotsky the earlier
attempt
and the whole network the nkvd put
together how much money money they spent
on it
and right up until when i was finishing
the book there was a biography that came
out i just caught it in time to be able
to use it
a biography of one of the key
members of the hit squad
that went after that organized the
commando raid
wonderful wonderfully informative
biography based on again those documents
so we can't get in especially now
especially in the last decade but others
did and i believe if you believe the
reviews that my
account of the trotsky murder is is uh
is the most complete that we have so far
and it's helped in part because i found
some great materials here at the hoover
institution archives where i did a lot
of my research
also at the harvard archives where
trotsky's papers are right
um
i use the exile papers interesting point
trotsky's papers have been there for a
very long time
um in fact he sold his papers to harvard
just before he died and on the morning
he was struck august 20
he received a telegram
saying that his papers had arrived safe
at harvard
six thousand dollars is what harvard
paid all of six thousand dollars quite
amazing
so but but the exile papers
which means everything from 1929
when trotsky was exiled from the soviet
union all the way up until his death
those were not open
to scholars
until 1980
and because of that well not to all
scholars isaac deutscher who wrote the
classic trilogy of trotsky the prophet
arm the prophet unarmed the prophet
outcast had access
to those archives but you had to trust
him
and he was not great for sources uh not
always uh and uh when it came to the
affair with freda he just looked the
other way he couldn't believe it was
happening he was sort of flustered you
can't blame him he wrote he was writing
in the 1950s
so but but the deutsche biography had
some access to this but the spate of
biographies of trotsky that came out of
the 1970s no one had access to the arc
to the exile papers
and so people then kind of lose interest
in trotsky
and then when they regain interest in
trotsky and it really starts with
dimitri volcagonov a former uh
soviet army general who writes uh these
great biographies in the early 1990s and
has access to the archives
when those come out everyone is focused
not on harvard they're focused on what
you're asking about we want to get into
the archives and see what's there so in
fact what i found as i began to research
the book is that there's there was a lot
of great stuff at harvard
and then here
hoover inherited the papers of the
socialist workers party that was
trotsky's party
in america
and you would be surprised because
hoover has a reputation of course for
being a conservative think tank but
there are many people on the left who
will give their papers to the hoover
archives because they know they'll be
well taken care of and their researchers
will have access to them and so on great
stuff the bodyguards those teamsters and
others the papers are here so i was able
to use those and so all that taken
together i pulled together the story of
the murder in a way that um hadn't been
done before
one more question
yes one more question come on up
okay i'll repeat it
right
both are used i i decided i think
largely for aesthetic purposes to avoid
trotskyite
which sounds like you know you've got to
call in clark pest pest control or
something i don't know trotskyite just
sounds a little funny to me trotskyist
was used
and i decided to go with that and be
consistent all the way through except
where i quoted people saying trotskyite
trotskyite sounds
sounds less neutral somehow to me than
trotskyist so i decided um to go with
that
oh no the word
is as old as as you know um well the
russian revolution may be
but really when trotsky is in exile
there are there's an american trotsky
ite party trotskyist party you see both
but the trotskyite thing just grates on
the ear to me so i decided not not to
use that folks thanks for coming out see
you all um again
thanks
bertrand patanot is the author of the
big show in bolo land the american
relief expedition to soviet russia in
the famine of 1921.
he's currently a research fellow at the
hoover institution find out more visit
hoover.org